[Música]
boa tarde pessoal prazer imenso estar
aqui de volta em casa
é curioso que essa primeira palestra eu
vou dar na paraíba depois de passar todo
mundo inteiro e é uma das mais especiais
com certeza hoje quero falar com vocês
sobre a intersecção de coisas é eu sou
apaixonado pela arquitetura e design é
desconhecida sendo com eles mas em que o
espaço na resposta patrulha e quando
estava rápido eu percebi que nós
qualquer retrocesso falava de espaço
tempo todo na escola políticas públicas
na área de tecnologias falava de dados
serviço mas eu pensava que por nossa
vida a integração dessas três coisas
então o trabalho começou daí mas eu
quero falar um pouco da minha origem
como fui parar fazendo essas coisas eu
sou aqui nessa terra linda a terra mais
ao leste das américas que tem sua beleza
natural e humana é tão incrível riqueza
cultural única mesmo sou apesar de
bastante esgotável resultado da mistura
de branco os índios e negros como vocês
a maioria pelo menos e cresci com aquele
espírito revolucionário né que a gente
revolução cubana fidel time mas percebi
que ele tinha um perfil a linha e queria
saber como podia fazer algo sustentável
e mais coerente que grandes é mudança
não se tornassem portas para a
autocracia e aí eu quis estudar duas
escolas a escola da vida andar na rua
jogar bola é fazer tudo o que a criança
tem que fazer ea escola formal e ativa
sorte pela educação recebida nos pais de
trabalhar muito e para rafa que com
bolsa integral
lá eu peço que se aprende mais sobre a
vida ea história dos três líderes que
mais inspiram é que são ganhe o mar do
parque mandela que ao fim de suas
carreiras todos praticavam que eu acho
que a grande mudança na revolução que a
resistência pacífica teve três outros
caras foram muito importantes para mim
mais um campo mais filosófico a
filosofia tudo
primeiro a gente tem que falou que feliz
aquele que sente com o próprio coração e
pensar com a própria cabeça
o 20 mensagens escreveu tratado da
lógica público era um gênio matemático e
com toda humildade do mundo foi ensinar
crianças de primário para entender como
a mente humana funciona acreano eo
emanuel kant que fala uma coisa foi
fundamental pra mim você só sabe aquilo
que você faz parte
então depois disso comecei a pensar eu
vim aqui no brasil essa polarização que
a gente vê tão forte hoje um lado o pt
eo psdb
esse número de movimentos sociais e não
sentindo os dados eram verdadeiras
então eu decidi não queria ser iguais
cachorro que fica escutando seu mexe o
que os outros dizem tomando com verdade
eu queria explodir esta vitória e saber
o erro o que estava lá fora
então eu comecei a pesquisar lá em
harvard pouco mais formal e desafios do
planeta hoje na minha opinião só a
igualdade o processo de urbanização
mudança climática e nessa questão da
humanização e desenrola neste clima que
o ponto convergente são as favelas de um
majoritário
vocês podem notar que uma tal de cabeça
para baixo e é de propósito porque
quando se fala muito rico e muito
desenvolvida a gente esquece que a gente
a maioria américa latina áfrica e ásia
83% população mundial e 93% do processo
de urbanização de 2050 vai sendo
majoritário um grande desafio e que hoje
um em cada sete pessoas vivem em favelas
só que até 2050 um em cada três e
ninguém conseguiu integrar uma favela
que seja no mundo nem mercadinho
então decidi aprender como resolver isso
quando voltei do rio eu fiz eu vou
separar daquilo que eu quero entender
quero saber
fui morar na favela do vidigal na rede
uma charge urbana chamada web que irá
limitar o espaço físico construído e
natural imediato o que acontece em
termos quantitativos e qualitativos para
ver se funcionava desenvolver soluções
ganhar sem escalas para outras favelas
lugares do mundo como hoje nedim lima
cidade do méxico cidade do cabo na
áfrica do sul mas a gente tem que
devolver um novo jeito de desenhar né
venho eu até de hardware martírios
lugares de pessoal porque é mais
importante são as pessoas e nós estamos
distribuindo sem espaço e nós
interagimos 39 trocando conhecimento com
o espaço e com apenas uma das pessoas
que a gente transformar esse espaço
instrumentos e esses instrumentos
viraram tecnologia e criar um novo
espaço digital
então toda vez que qualquer pessoa nos
titulares em qualquer coisa que não
deseja um prédio de uma política pública
não devem honrar um software desenhado
essa matriz
essa experiência do usuário e um
processo de abertura é muito complicado
porque é sempre assim um projeto bonito
e acabou aquele projeto vai pular pra
outra gente queria fazer um contínuo pra
trazer evidência científica para o
desenho do espaço de escolas hospitais e
outras coisas a gente desenha é aliás
pesquisa desenha e depois envolve e
quando a gente faz a primeira fase de
desenvolvimento a gente faz a segunda
fase de pesquisa eo aprendizado essa
quase alimenta a segunda fase design e
por aí vai então a gente brinca muito é
melhor para o nosso trabalho aqui nunca
acaba
depois daí a gente foi definir pouco mas
tudo bem vá trabalhar favela do vidigal
mas são quais são as escalas de trabalho
design que influenciam o que a gente
quer fazer
ele descobriu que o partido ia desde da
nanotecnologia biotecnologia e fazendo
um mapeamento 3d de áreas subterrâneas
a cheia dos rios voadores que é o que
permite ter água no sudeste do brasil e
do sudeste a américa do sul corresponde
a 70% do pib da região e está no sistema
muito crítico agora devido ao
desmatamento bolhas de calor de
densidade concreta e outras coisas então
a primeira coisa que aconteceu para
minha surpresa foi que minha tese lá em
harvard virou uma aula em um estúdio na
escola de desenho é lá nos estados
unidos da própria raiva ea idéia era
criar um novo conceito escolas que da
educação melhor mas embaixadora mais
inovadora mas também civis como os
roubos de integração das favelas no
processo do pp es e esse projeto de 12
projetos que fizemos foram lá no
complexo do alemão que é o berço de
todas as facções de droga no brasil no
momento único da história que estava o
pt começando um ser impossível os por
exemplo mas foi bem marcante sair e
pilhas ordem que quando estava na favela
rafa me deu uma bolsa de pesquisa pra
passar um ano viajando por cinco países
seis cidades
pesquisando que tenha funcionado não
tenha funcionado integração urbana
sustentabilidade resiliência não só em
termos de arquitetura mas também de
políticas públicas tecnologia e aí disso
foi que a gente criou todos os nossos
projetos então a gente decidiu porém tem
uma oportunidade incrível de pensar no
pior dos maiores problemas da humanidade
desafio então vamos focar em ganhar
dinheiro fazer o que tiver mais impacto
e que as soluções que em uma escala que
o primeiro grande nome que recebeu foi
da democracia porque a gente viu nos
protege 2003 na primavera árabe é nos
protestos continuaram pela europa norte
da áfrica estados unidos mesmo que
existe um problema representatividade
então a gente fez pouco vão entender
como é que surgiu a democracia ea grande
descoberta foi que a democracia foi uma
reforma tanto política quanto espacial
vamos falar surge na grécia mas ninguém
sabe com então para 349 de um paper sob
vasos cerâmicos gregas e reencontrou
eles dividiram a cidade em dez áreas e
com o mesmo número de habitantes
1.500 cada um e cada uma dessas áreas
não dava 50 pessoas por poder executivo
para decidir o que é que esse efeito na
cidade de atenas
tirando esse poder de uma aristocracia
chamado eram pagos que era fechada mas o
que aconteceu foi que nosso sistema
democrático que recebeu
não foi baseado na grécia não tem nada a
ver foi baseado no fórum romano que foi
feito para ser aristocrático então essa
crise que a gente vê esse conflito e
clássicas maneira que em breve uma coisa
social no brasil vêm muito desse
problema de desenho
daí a gente passou a pensar uma solução
por dias atuais especializado em uma
frase do livro da cidade porque tem um
grande problema é que as câmaras de
vereadores são os grandes culpados pelo
que a gente chama o programa da cidade
dividida que você vai ver no rio de
janeiro são paulo cidade do cabo um
bairro que é o que quem tem dinheiro têm
futuro e quem não tem nas preferências
nas favelas do morro como o caso do rio
não tem porque quem decide as cidades
são os vereadores e eles têm os dois
principais incentivos para a corrupção
descrição ninguém sabe que eles fazem e
poder
quem é que vai lá e comanda as camas
vereadores são as construtoras então que
a gente propôs hoje vamos acabar com os
vereadores que estatisticamente faz
nenhum sentido e vamos fazer cada espaço
em cada bairro em cada comunidade vai
ver um lugar onde as pessoas podem votar
diretamente no lugar do vereador para
fazer a cidade uma vez por semana ou
duas que seja
e aí a gente propôs a pegação políticas
públicas para a tecnologia foi publicado
em harvard foi muito bom
as do projeto o equipamento comunidade e
integração caso vídeo é bom e criamos um
programa que seria como uma escola um
hospital
chama-se agora digital não tenham espaço
sistematização que se prendem com as
coisas funcionam
o espaço de síntese para entregar a
produção de design e programação estúdio
com uma vez em tecnologia para uma área
de articulação que seria pra democracia
direta atividades culturais debates e o
que aconteceu foi que é ilegal a gente
fez prédio grandes investidores do rio
prefeito queria construir a gente ficou
esperando e não rolou sobre a comunidade
comprou a idéia e fez o mesmo que não
vai refazer a entrada do vidigal
a gente quer fazer esse espaço fiscal é
que vocês têm aí de material é escutada
no lixão de 20 toneladas de entulho
limpo muito pneu velho
caramba você conseguir fazer alguma
coisa aí conseguimos fazer os caras
vocês querem mesmo é que a gente quer
decidir nosso espaço porque o vidigal
está sofrendo ao processo
identificação do rio de janeiro para que
mais valorizou as construtoras querem
tomar a favela da gente e beleza vão
fazer então a gente pegou o núcleo do
programa da globo digital
em vez de fazer com mármore ace viro a
gente fez nesse espaço o que existe ali
com pneus com escombros de concreto não
é claro em trechos detenção de extensão
é fizemos altura e base qualificamos e
aí foi esse espaço que surgiu no vidigal
a primeira coisa que a gente fez eu
nunca pensei que daria uma coisa dessa
mas eu pensei comigo mesmo a gente tem
que fazer o que faz impacto na vida das
pessoas não esperar as condições ideais
mas as condições existentes
daí o partido virou símbolo do rio de
janeiro às olimpíadas considerado o
maior legado da sociedade civil nesse
processo olímpico é a gente focou muito
na questão da história religiosa é um
problema grave entre os evangélicos e as
religiões afro brasileiras e é muito
incrível pra gente que hoje nos sabores
e nos domingos mas geralmente mais
sabores
o pessoal do candomblé realizado amanhã
e depois o evangelho e de tarde e eles
começaram a aproximar os horários e aí
de repente ficaram amigos e aí a gente
perguntou depois que o evangelho porque
ele sempre um depois dos solos candomblé
eles eram que é porque eles iam rezar
pelo pessoal do candomblé
a gente está também estão realizando é
melhor que um jogando pedra no outro né
e o que é incrível da democracia a gente
nasce pobre nação hoje é que a
democracia se espaços públicos para se
desenvolver para a democracia é preciso
que as pessoas confiam nas outras e
possam assim dialogar quando a gente tem
espaços urbanos agregados como a gente
tem hoje condomínios horríveis calçadas
sem gente e você encontra pessoas iguais
a você no shopping que é um pseudo
espaço público que é feito só para
consumo não produção diálogo é evolução
nada disso então a gente quis focar
muito nessa questão integrar também a
tecnologia de ponta
outra coisa muito importante o
protagonismo das mulheres é comunidade
negra e uma das coisas mais bonitas que
aconteceu né o mauro então ele é o
fundador do partido nascido e criado no
vidigal dando aulas o pessoal do mit e
de harvard não acham que o conhecimento
contextual inteligência do local é tão
importante quanto à educação formal que
a gente tem em qualquer lugar do mundo e
é isso que tem que entender para fazer
renovações realmente impacto da gente
fez o masterplan do vidigal né
aqui dentro o primeiro projeto pra auto
sustentável de energia água e esgoto que
é uma água na escala maior
fizemos um projeto para as escada e 31
fogo ganhou prêmios estados unidos na
bienal de veneza que é um assim se chama
de resiliência de contenção de encosta
um grave problema da erosão vocês sabem
é um espaço público é radical ligado aos
negócios locais e 99% da superfície da
escada é um sistema de coleta tratamento
e distribuição de água porque a crise
agora que estava em são paulo vai
aumentar então toda o que a gente tem
coletar e aproveitar o máximo e só vai
piorar
infelizmente então a gente tem que
passar dessa fase desenhar só escala da
arquitetura urbanismo pra mobilidade
outras coisas e pensa na integração com
o território próprio desenho do
território
daí a gente pegou e fez uma modelagem
matemática é primeiro modelo 3d do morro
do vidigal para entender o caminho das
águas depois a modelagem matemática com
jogos aos profissionais para saber de
onde vinha a gente captou essa água ela
virá água preta que quando a água bate
em um espaço construído ela só pode ser
tratada por ser descartado
a gente aguentou sendo perdida no cerco
na favela no rio vocês sabem né
quando tem uma crise de água na região
onde se corta primeiro é o suprimento
são músicas mais pobres nas favelas no
interior
aí a gente pegou e fez o projeto parque
e proposta da prefeitura é adaptar uma
série de legislações e partes agente
emissor t
nosso conselho de fundadores highline o
centropark do clube espanhol ea gente
propôs criar um parque oficial criado e
liderado por uma comunidade no
território mais valorizado do rio das
construções mas queriam comprar ea gente
conseguiu foi nossa medalha de ouro
olímpica
lá no vidigal aqui algumas das vezes
vocês podem ver e ipanema/leblon um
lugar que você vê no rio de janeiro ela
gol de diferença na forma de coração e
fala muito você fazer o caminho do céu
para chegar no coração do rio e também
nosso plano de 50 anos estratégico para
o parque para o vidigal virou o plano
base na verdade da cidade do rio de
janeiro para os próximos 50 anos de
idade de seus 500 anos com uma grande
vitória
conseguimos que o projeto começa com a
escala pequena desenhando com materiais
que havia no local pneus entulho uns
muito o pretensão virasse uma política
pública a na cidade olímpica do brasil e
da américa do sul
depois disso mas vamos trabalhar a
questão de mapeamento digital 3d né
tanto a superfície como da parte
subterrânea para fazer previsões e
cenários presentes climáticos extremos
que é um grande problema que 98% dos
desastres naturais que vão acontecendo
muito tem acontecido com você nas áreas
mais pobres do mundo majoritário o que é
uma grande injustiça quem mais poluiu
foi os países ricos já está pagando a
conta então como a gente se adapta a
tudo isso com isso em terrenos planos
terreno de morro
daí que um adulto e uma das maiores da
nossa essa criança primeiro a integração
urbana e resiliência estava você tem que
fazer o desenho território para depois
fazer a escala do organismo depois da
abertura virou base de matriz de
dezembro e rápida da escola de design
fundada pelo walter grupos que também é
o fundador da barra então isso é uma
honra muito grande recuperou e faz parte
desse grupo aí também outra coisa muito
importante foi provar que a inovação
pode nascer da favela para o asfalto
integrando o conhecimento da gente um
conhecimento da comunidade produzem
soluções que fossem efectivas que as
pessoas podem porém não só usar mas se
apropriar da sua produção como baixando
os pneus que acham do sistema de
drenagem que entre outras coisas
só que o grande problema é que no brasil
onde uma crise tremenda violência uma
ditadura da corrupção que vai da favela
até brasília
o que a gente tem aprendido com o texto
do vidigal é que não adianta fazer um
trabalho profissional é inovador de alto
impacto
num país como o brasil a gente tem
transformar o estado em transformar
política porque o que acontece aqui as
crises de violência primeiro aparece no
morro depois descem pelo asfalto e se
espalham pelas cidades
o que a gente tem visto é muito
interessante que as crises de violência
têm o mesmo padrão disposição matemático
de crise de saúde levando muitos
profissionais da área conter a crise
saúde principalmente um problema de
saúde pública e outra coisa muito
interessante a informalidade ea questão
da mudança climática afeta muito o
aumento da violência e principalmente
contém a conjunção falta d'água
corrupção e falta de infraestrutura em
geral aí os indicadores não há
correlação maior ainda mas tem esperança
né tem 12 grandes amigos foram mentores
trabalho um design elegante e velhos são
mais próximo que criou o ambiente social
em medellín e os é de facto o prefeito
fez a mudança no processo de matemática
e eles vinham situação muito parecida
com a nossa lá e medinho na época pós
pablo escobar né terra arrasada toda
pública tomada pelos agentes corruptos
do tráfico eles querem uma coalizão que
a colisão nem criar o brasil sociedade
civil setor privado e academia juntos
porque essa classe política está aí vai
fazer nada pela gente
bom seus renan já os seus punhos seus
palotes de seus vai ser usar estes voos
e as serras tem que ser vocês
e foi isso que eles fizeram lá então a
gente agora a partir para um novo novo
momento negativo que pessoas desenham a
política pública das pessoas
então nossa grande meta pra dormir 17 e
18 é como a gente pode construir junto à
agência nacional uma visão que o brasil
se torne um país em educação inovação
sustentabilidade e que a gente recupere
nossa esperança é que nada que preste
tudo mas vem com lembrar que a gente o
país de princesa isabel
a deputada antonieta de barros a
primeira capital do brasil pai de santo
do mundo que imitou avião o país de
cartola e dona zica tom e vinicius o
país de paulo freire pelé e alice chico
de chico science lina bo bardi de cena e
sérgio vieira de mello e dos caras que
mais admiro no rio né oscar minha manhã
e os fundadores de park city e que
começar esse trabalho limpando o
zetas é 20 toneladas de leite sozinho só
que depois de conseguir limpar mais 15
já só nesse ano e que fizeram um marco
histórico porque na cidade olímpica um
tanto investimento principal legado
nasceu de uma favela da cabeça dos caras
com esse e com gente boa de fora como a
gente aqui servindo como instrumento
então que eu quero que vocês levem a
mensagem que não adianta com bom seja
que você faz o que você faz tão bom se
você fazer qualquer coisa sua origem o
que importa você deve cair para melhorar
o mundo ir lá no campo das pessoas vivem
e sofrem sonho se juntar a elas e
trabalhar com elas e use o que tiver mas
nunca abriu mão de construir novos
mundos com os sonhos ea estética que
você deseja
muito obrigado